はい、もうオーケーです、皆の言いたいことはわかります！もう、どうせまた来るんでしょ？
「お金持ちですね」「金の無駄遣い」「粗末にすんな」
そんなことオレが一番わかってるよっ！！
ま、今回はもう見てわかるとおり、ここにね、コーラが、ちょっと机上に出せなくて、
段ボールで6箱おいてるんですけれど、
120L、置いてあります
メントスが、何個だ？
72個置いてあるんですけど
今日は何とですねですねぇ
コーラ120リットルを使ってお風呂にコーラ風呂を作って
そこに、メントス、メントスを
体中に付けて
そのままコーラ風呂に入ります
え、もったいないってぇ？
ばかやろう
男だぞ、男
人生一度きりっだぜ、
夢、叶えようぜ！
ま、別に夢じゃないんですけどぉ…
まなんか外国の方がプールで同じような事やってたんで、
ま、Japanese魂が燃えたと言うかね
ま、僕は負けずにね
日本の強さ、
サムライJapanをね、見せてやろうと思うんすよ
はい、先にもう浴槽の方にコーラを全部移動させました
はい。
こんな、感じです
メントスを全部、出します
中身を
でぇきました。
まっつ、
めっちゃ多い
はいっ
それでここからどうするかって言うと
まず体中に
そうだね、うん
ドア閉めよう
体中にメントスをつけなければいけません。
で、僕考えたのは
コーラメントスが反応して爆発するのは
炭酸のせいなんすよ。
僕がコーラをお風呂に入れた瞬間
できるだけ早くお風呂に入りたい訳です。
てことは、メントス全部を体に纏う時、
付けるのに時間を取ってたらもったいないんで、
この、透明なセロハンテープで
メントス一個一個を、こう、貼りつけて
こういう感じです
こういうなんか輪っかを作って
メントスをくっつけて、この状態！
全部この状態にして置いておきます
コーラ全部入れたら、速攻これを、こう、体に
こういう感じでね！
ペタペタ貼って
ダイブするっていう。
そういう作戦でございます
じゃ、早速やっていきましょう
ヤバい！ちょっと終わんない、これ。
終わんない気がしてきた
すいません、ちょっと作戦変更です
ちょっとメントス入れてたら、ちょっと時間がなくなりそうなんで
先に！コーラ風呂をセットします！
まず、浴槽にボトルごと入れれるまで入れておきます
もちろんあれですよ！
コーラ風呂、入る時は蓋を全部開けます
ちゃんと口がある方が、反応した時に
圧が、かかるんで
爆発すると思うんで
発射前に全部蓋を開けるんで、
安心しておいてください
では！こちらをお風呂に入れていきます。
あ〜、シュワシュワ言ってる。もうダメだ。
え、無理だ。ガンガン行っちゃおう。
よし、よし、よし、よし、よし。
あ〜、飲みてー！
急げ、急げ、急げ。
よし、よし、次、次、次
はいはい。いいよ。次。
もうちょい、もうちょい、もうちょい
もうちょい。
よし！ラストだ、ラスト。
よ〜し。全部終わった〜。
はい！という訳で、今、コーラの風呂ができたんで
ちょっと時間がないので、早く、メントスを体に付けます
ヤバい！時間がない！
時間との戦いだ！
ヤベェ
ヤバいヤバい
ヤバい！
ヤバい！ギリギリだ！
もう！！これでいいです！！
これで行きます！
どうすか、この…
この感じにね、風呂に飛び込もうと思います
いろいろと、いろいろとヤバいんで、やっちゃいます
なんでこれしてるかって言うと
爆発する時は、圧力がかかんないとダメなんすよ
こういう細い蓋の。
一回、圧迫されないと
コーラは飛ばないんで
圧迫口を、今、解放しています
お〜し、行くぞ！
行くぞ！！
じゃ、もう行きますね
1、行くぞ！！
え？
え〜？ちょっ…と
ちょっと？ちょっと！？
ま、まあまあ。
ま、こんなもんだって事はちょっとわかってましたよ
くっそぉ！！！